[Musique]
bonjour bonjour
et bien aujourd'hui en opposition avec
ce que maïté aime bien les soupes
chaudes qui tiennent au corps un les
soupes consistante nourrissent verdure
la soupe de pois cassés à toutes les
bonnes choses elle attend pour faire
quelque chose totalement différent alors
qu'est ce que vous voulez nous proposer
on va faire des soupes froides 1 pour
les journées chaudes
alors qu'est-ce que ça y'en a été vous
voulez nous proposer un gaspacho andalou
on peut le faire comme on veut c'est à
dire que c'est un plat délicieux que le
monde entier demande aujourd'hui voilà
attendu mais chacun prétend avoir la
meilleure recette
alors on va voir comment ça ce qui le
rend la meilleure recette et puis une
soupe au concombre qui est bonne aussi
et qui se mange froid aussi
tout est froid bon et apprécié de soupe
si nous reste un tout petit peu de temps
qu'est-ce que vous avez nous fait rêver
on va faire les fameuses amuse-bouche
jeunesse bouche que vous parlez vous
voilà un musée gueule c'est ce qu'elle
voulait dire je ne savais pas là c'est
alors qu'est ce qu'il vous faut pour les
supports comme alors on est souple il en
faut du père me voyais à papeete
deviendra arrière et ces régimes et les
lycées léger alors des peines des
oignons des poivrons rouges blancs et
gens de toutes les couleurs du laurier
de la nette de la et des tomates du de
l'estragon des percées du thème un
chouïa oulala si vous en avez vous nous
en envoyer ses célèbres disent que
c'était d'ailleurs du cercueil
voilà bien entendu les en diffusera bear
l'amuse-gueule sur nasri et puis alors
très importants décombres
et voilà et le laurier et on va beaucoup
changer tout ça et bien on va commencer
par quoi par le gaspacho on a coupé les
légumes en petits morceaux alors les
maîtres que nous avons là nous avons ça
c'est les pauvres onze jours de ça c'est
les poivrons rouges ça c'est les pauvres
anvers les concombres sas et l'oignon et
l'ail et la tomate
qu'est ce qu'on va faire un petit ça
revient vers toulouse inpt est adorable
alors vous me les donner je tourne
vivent en assurant de bonnes traditions
larrouy l'humanité on pourrait mixer oui
mais nous mais notre hachoir c'est aussi
nos vieilles traditions dans le vieil
ami de bien
des années la regarder et pardonnez moi
un peu autre chose à réfléchir un peu et
si vous voulez donner maintenant les ja
nasillard jaune du poivron rouge
alors vous allez vous le maître ça
passerait bien je vais mettre un petit
peu de mes deux frères très bien alors
je manuela je vais mettre un peu de vert
que ça va faire très bon un peu
d'oignons qui donnera beaucoup de bon
goût ça fait joli paraissent très très
bien c'est parfait quoi puis de nouveau
un peu de concours après vingt cinq ans
vous vous y pensez de maïté je vais
faire tout si pauvre plaisir
il nous en faut beaucoup là moi je vais
le mettre dans ma grande soupe hier mon
grand saladier
bon ça que je vais continuer 1 je
reviendrai la ménagère mois
et pourquoi vous allez me donner de la
mi-temps pour la rue sainte hélène bien
sûr l'appareil attendez je tourne là je
retourne je retourne je retourne et la
mie de pain ça va épaissir ça bien sûr
ça va vous arriver un petit peu jules a
fait exprès c'est exprès pour que tous
fassent un rapide le patron parce que
j'ai encore des légumes à m moi j'ai
regardé j'ai encore plein de tonnac là
qu'il ne manque qu'à vous laisser un peu
de chaque oui mais si vous voulez mais
je veux garder ma robe à mal alors un
camion six semaines tout ça voilà je
crois que vous savez il y en aura bien
toi c'est un que jamais assez parce que
les nombreux une série de garde-fous
mieux nous y aurait bon ça alors encore
un petit peu croyaient qu'il n'en faut
encore un peu oui
la régie à daisy la voilà on va remettre
vous avez mis de toula il m'avait dit
vous en laisse et six agents normal des
jeux en famille est là et ma belle
allons-y pour l'art
voilà c'était un petit peu de progrès
oui puis je vais vous finir les tomates
on ne refera vous un petit peu parce
qu'on a besoin de jus la voix la
violence et ça je crois qu on y vend
très bien mais qu'est ce que vous allez
en faire ensuite allé manger notre sac
dans d'autres saladier le pain sera
beaucoup épaissie l'a1
voilà ses bières on va tout mélanger
puis vous allez me raconter ce que vous
allez faire
après alors maintenant aux verts un
passé encore mais oui mon chinois
maintenant grâce à votre 505 france info
que ce soit une petite optique ou lit là
avec sa basse et bien peut-être mais
bien sur terre regarde et là ça va être
parfait là et comme ça il y aura plus
qu'une petite houle est jolie comme tout
vu
oui un jus très parti né sait très bien
beau les deux joues le continue et bien
si vous voulez je vous en remettre
d'autres et moi pendant ce temps je vais
préparer les i la source ce qu'on peut
dire la vinaigrette en a fait zone mans
un assaisonnement relevé un petit pas ça
très bien
alors qu'est ce que vous allez mettre
dedans simple un peu de sel du vinaigre
normal oui voilà un peu
alors là très peu trop attention parce
que quelquefois vous avez la main un peu
lourde sur les épices moi je vous
rappelle qu'on s'appelle du tabasco
tabasco c'est la trique 1 je crois
d'origine ou canaliser la nascar est
relevé
voilà ça c'est fort et ça c'est très
très fort vous avez mélanger tous âges
mélanger tous ça y est c'est que moi je
pense que c'est pas mal
bien entendu mais ça c'est pas mal déjà
été remis en état
je veux faire couler un peu c'est bien
carrément d'honneur à les voir très bien
si ces jolis seins regarder si c'est
joli alors je vais y mettre la vie des
grimpeurs dessus non mélangés et
maintenant je vais comme sur le monte à
l'huile d'olive il vous allez vous
obtenez votre que ça bouge
là j'ai retrouvé très vite ou et pas
trop ou pas trop où on en est et centre
trop gras prés vous croyez qu'en mais il
faut quand même un peu voilà il n'y aura
plus qu'à le mettre au frais au oui
parce qu'il faut que ce soit servi glacé
au mieux 12h évidemment si l'on peut
alors qu'on annonce que nous on va
peut-être préparer la soupe de concombre
soupe de concombre qui est excellente
combien faut-il compter de concombres
par personne - heures au moins au moins
on n'a pas une blague qu'est ce que vous
en faites leur donner hg je vais tourner
la molette la molina là bas j'y vais j'y
vais là ça va très bien et vous qu'est
ce que vous allez faire pendant ça ne
veut laisser passer à faire sur tout
mais sûrement pas bon alors je vais
finir de pelé un autre concours là ça
passe bien j'espère où ils savent aller
très très bien ça c'est vous encore une
fois pourrait le faire au mixeur mais
nous on a nos vieilles habitudes avec
nos vieux amis comme on a toujours fait
nous voilà on continue nous ne sommes
pas moderne
bon alors qu'aurélien ça va ça va aller
vous que vous êtes en train de faire la
revue the mois mais à quoi vous vous
amusez le fort je dis je veux luchin
alors je vais faire des petites boules
ou très joli ça avec la petite cuillère
spéciales es7 du travail raffiné maïté
je vois un bain on appelle ça du
bricolage
ça y est ça marche vous devez organiser
un petit peu en verser dans la rue parce
que j'u faire une bonne soupe avec du
bon jus sa valeur de se passait très
bien
l'argent versé vous allez c'est qu'on a
encore un petit peu a passé la abonde
très bien mais ça pète on dit nous
perdons pas de temps et moi n'a été
ouvert une proposition pandore je
continue à passer c'est vous donner ça
j'imagine que vous avez passé au tamis
alors je peux déjà vous donner ça va
passer parce que j'aimerais ça pour moi
pendant ce temps je termine que vous
avez donné on va faire joli petit coulis
est une soupe
excepté d'une soupe froide c'est pour
rien se voit mais c'est bon une fois que
c'est passé
bon et frais vous vendre d'autres oui je
vous en donne d'autres ça y est je
voulais pas si milla la mort du mois de
juin après je vais lâcher des petites
herbes de d'un on va finir tout ça mais
je vous garantis que ce sera bon là j'ai
rajouté un peu de pulpe et parce que
c'était liquid liquid parce que c'est
pas très facile à passer une heure indue
tout
voilà bon et allart ensuite il faut peut
être assaisonnée un peu tout ça oui
parce que c'est s'adapter
vous êtes généreux non mais c'est
généreux l'add on a ensuite envahi
maître du yaourt
ah oui voilà vous me l'a expliqué qu'ils
avaient le choix si on veut garder sa
ligne comme vous et moi en mai du yaourt
si l'on tient moins gardé sa ligne on
met de la crème fraîche voilà comme on
veut ensuite je vais y mettre mes
petites herbes que je vais préparer
alors là ça c'est de les migrants oui je
vais le coupé sera donné un bon petit
parfum d'estragon maintenant vous elle
prépare et plein d'autres choses aussi
planète où ça va faire une soupe
rafraîchissant quelque chose de
délicieux voilà de l'aneth
ensuite un petit peu de persil je vais h
et aussi bien que je vais pouvoir
ce mélange de personnes s'arrêtent pour
sa part ça me fait déjà en ville
tellement sale et rafraîchissant et
agréable ça mériterait pire que moi et
ne s'est pas un défaut c'est peut-être
apaisé mais c'est pas un défaut après un
petit peu de cerfeuil alors à l'église
on dit plus tellement que vous faire
contre une contrition si on a fait le
péché de gourmandise
vous allez vous vous confesser au curé
car ayant que ceux plus mentalement je
fais pas empêché alors on va les mettre
s'en va le mettre là pour faire joli et
que si 4
et puis alors les petits boules que j'ai
fait avec le concombre en sauvant fond
pourquoi certains sont des liquides on
va être trouvé mon jeu on savait drogue
et tout ça aux frais et touchant au
frais pendant au moins une heure on a le
temps de faire nos amuse-gueules naïveté
je crois mais bien sûr comment ce que
vous allez vous y prend ses prêts
faciles pour mélanger dire que fort de
la crème fraîche ah oui et puis regardez
les petites feuilles d'endives ça sert
de barquettes vous y mettrez ben écoutez
c'est pas plus difficile je donnais
arrimer nos biscuits salés tout près et
ça va être meilleur exactement jolie
plus originales voilà alors
nous tartiner sa soigneusement ça y est
et alors cela alors cela c'est encore un
petit peu plus fort vous allez voir ça
cet excès de sébum une petite cuillère
avec de la crème au pire qu'il faut
mieux commencer par voir la crème
fraîche il ajouté peu à peu leurs
efforts parce que la dic c'est faire
l'espèce de radis mais c'est tres la
grèce et le radis noir qui est très fort
voilà alors que valérie defert dedans il
ya du verre et de la cible la cible est
un faux et inventé le tout voilà vous y
mettez vingt deuxième et bien écoutez ça
fait un amuse gueule comme vous dites
très joli trait à ce jour un très bon
voila voila et puis ensuite on n'a plus
qu'à sortir du frêne au dessous la soupe
au concombre avec l'inde est délicieuse
dedans exactement et le fameux gaspacho
concert avec des petits légumes qu'on a
parsemé de sutton ma route et voilà
croyez moi pour un jour chaud j'espère
bien froid c'est beau alors dans la
pythie ya bientôt bon appétit et mercier
[Musique]